[Musica]
questo al mio fianco è un robot
io adesso mi avvicino e con un semplice
gesto
gli faccio iniziare un suo programma che
eseguirà durante la mia presentazione
questo termine così evocativo robot
nasce nel 1920 dal dramma del ceco karel
capek dramma si chiamava ruhr che
significa rossom universal robot in
questo dramma il dottor rossom creava
dei robot a in cieco dei lavoratori in
grado di lavorare al posto dell'uomo
questo al fine di liberare l'umanità
dalla schiavitù
l'epilogo però fu tragico e i robot
presero il sopravvento sull'umanità
io oggi sono qui per illustrarvi uno
scenario decisamente migliore perché
l'uomo crea oggi i robot li crea per
fargli fare quelle mansioni ripetitive
usuranti pericolose che altrimenti
sarebbe l'uomo in questa foto vedete un
ambiente di lavoro ostile questa è una
forza le persone sono a contatto con
metallo liquido estremamente pericoloso
un atmosfera oltre 50 gradi questo è un
lavoro da robot e questa è una catena di
montaggio chi vuole ancora lavorare in
catena di montaggio come faceva charlie
chaplin simpaticamente ripetendo la
stessa operazione per migliaia migliaia
di volte durante la giornata
questa è un'attività che devono fare i
robot e apriamo tutto quel mondo che è
della robotica che lavora in ambito
radioattivo ad esempio per lo
smantellamento delle centrali nucleari i
robot vengono telecomandati da remoto da
delle persone che altrimenti verrebbero
a contatto con la radioattività e quindi
contaminate
senza i robot non ci sarebbe quell
incredibile esperienza che la chirurgia
robotica per la medicina moderna in cui
i chirurghi sono in grado di operare da
new york a milano in tele controllo del
robot raggiungendo delle precisioni dei
dieci di mm è anche meglio
altrimenti impossibile con la mano
dell'uomo
in questa foto che probabilmente tutti
conoscete xkè molte pubblicità
i robot si vedono costruire le moderne
automobili che oggi tutti guidate vedete
tanti robot tanti perché i robot devono
produrre molte automobili molti pezzi
con la massima qualità ottenibile ma
soprattutto non vedete una cosa in
questa foto non vedete degli uomini
questo perché questi sono dei robot
industriali grandi veloci che esercitano
dei processi come la saldatura
estremamente pericolosi per l'uomo
i robot sono chiusi dentro a delle
gabbie ci sono delle barriere tra l'uomo
e il robot ma le barriere esistono per
essere abbattute
[Musica]
in questo video si s o finzione o realtà
vedete un robot industriale che gioca a
ping pong senza barriere con l'uomo
questo perché alcuni anni fa è nata una
tecnologia che chiamiamo robotica
collaborativa il robot collaborativi
come quello che sul palco sono dei robot
in grado di coesistere nella stessa area
e collaborare con le persone in maniera
sicura come lo fanno grazie a una fitta
rete di sensori che gestiscono
l'interazione con l'esterno questo robot
sul palco che sta lavorando mentre io
parlo si chiama l.br in tedesco
l.br significa robot leggero ed è dotato
di sette sensori di coppia quindi di
elettronica programmabile in
corrispondenza di ciascuno dei sette
giunti ma soprattutto è estremamente
leggero e quindi nel caso di un urto con
una persona non è traumatico non fa male
quindi sarà possibile in futuro avere un
robot come collega adesso io vi faccio
vedere un paio di video di quello che
invece l'oggi di robot che lavorano
fianco a fianco con le persone in questo
video vedete robot senza barriere che
aiuta l'operatrice a muovere un oggetto
che il differenziale di un'auto che pesa
più di dieci chili e soprattutto vedete
che gestisce in sicurezza una collisione
come questa altrimenti molto rischiosa
per l'operatrice con un robot
industriale tradizionale e guardate cosa
fa adesso un'altra operatrice ferma al
robot con una mano e lo fa riavviare
come ho fatto prima io
questo in una linea di montaggio nella
fattispecie di di lavatrici ma quindi i
robot effettivamente oggi collaborativi
sono all'interno delle aziende e la loro
caratteristica è che possono lavorare
fianco a fianco con le persone ma cosa
succederebbe se ad esempio aprissimo
casa nostra a un robot un robot
collaborativo
come questo che magari nella fattispecie
vedete che ha due braccia una
configurazione che noi diciamo umanoide
al mattino a colazione ci prepara quello
che penso sia un pancake
[Musica]
[Applauso]
diciamo che per adesso a colazione
continua a fare da solo ma in industria
perché no e infatti il mercato dei robot
collaborativi hoc o both che significa
collaborativa robot sta crescendo in
maniera incredibile fra cinque anni si
venderanno nel mondo lo stesso numero di
robot industriali e collaborativi cioè
500 mila e 500 mila robot collaborativi
quali sono i motivi di questa crescita
pazzesca e i driver sono due uno di
natura economica e un altro altri driver
di natura sociale e politica le aziende
vogliono sicurezza
questo è importante vogliono lavorare
senza barriere fianco a fianco con i
robot questi robot fanno questo mestiere
le aziende voglio spendere poco in
automazione e questo è un fattore
importante che vedremo anche dopo meno
rispetto ai robot industriali
tradizionali e vogliono un robot
semplice che si tocca con la mano che si
muove si programma questo perché oggi
produciamo degli oggetti dei lotti
sempre più piccoli è sempre più
personalizzati quella che si chiama mass
customization da un punto di vista
sociale e politico questo dà la
possibilità del boe crash o ring che
significa riportarci le produzioni in
paesi ad alto costo della manodopera
come ad esempio l'italia al fine di
contrastare la competizione globale
quindi di competere ancora con questi
paesi e in mente o fondamentalmente il
far east soprattutto da un punto di
vista sociale far fare le cose più
semplici e ripetitive come dicevo prima
a questi robot perché lo scopo dei robot
non è quello di mandare le persone a
casa ma di mantenere l'occupazione
dedicandole ad altre attività a nuove
mansioni che vedremo dopo
ma se apriamo tutto quel filone che non
è esattamente questo ma si chiama
robotica di servizio troviamo i robot
nel settore didattico educational come
questo
e magari alcuni di voi conoscono
robot assistiti come questo esoscheletro
che aiuta le persone a camminare oa fare
riabilitazione dei concept veri e propri
che a breve saranno industrializzati per
avere un robot in cucina un po più bravo
di quello che abbiamo visto nel video in
prima e io sono convinto che molti di
voi hanno già un robot in casa io ce
l'ho
aspira la polvere si muove in un
ambiente di cui non ha la cartina lo fa
in maniera automatica e sicura questo è
un po both vi torna forse alla mente
questa provocazione di bill gates
tassare i robot un anno e mezzo fa circa
piume bocciata dalla comunità europea è
fondamentalmente dalla comunità robotica
ovviamente e industriale passare più che
altro la competitività
anzi le aziende che hanno una
competitività aumentata grazie
all'utilizzo di automazione flessibile e
intelligente come questa
questo sarebbe solo un freno
all'innovazione e genererebbe il
fenomeno opposto del becker shoring e
quindi il re sharing cioè le aziende
vanno a produrre dove si pagano meno
tasse e dove costa meno
il lavoro d'altra parte quando è uscito
tanti anni fa oramai un pacchetto
software che aveva un foglio di calcolo
e un foglio di videoscrittura
nessuno ha proposto una tassa per questo
nonostante diverse mansioni chiaramente
poi siano cambiate c'è un'analisi di
mckinsey molto interessante che vi
invito ad andare a vedere che la vede da
un'ottica completamente diversa e
ottimistica bechis e stima nel 2030 700
milioni di persone che verranno
sostituite dai robot ma dedicate a delle
altre mansioni collaterali a quella dei
robot ovvero la gestione dei big data
questo robot sono un sacco di dati il
mio cellulare fa un sacco di dati
oggi siamo sui social tantissimi dati
che vanno gestiti la gestione delle
infrastrutture cloud che li devono
ospitare la creazione di applicazioni
cloud based finalizzate a attività ad
esempio di robotica collaborativa
e infine l'intelligenza artificiale
l'intelligenza artificiale è una cosa
che però già abbiamo sui nostri device
tutte queste tematiche sono racchiuse su
quella che si chiama quarta rivoluzione
industriale che per i robotici quindi
per me in effetti è la seconda
rivoluzione robotica quella dei co both
perché la prima coincide con la terza
rivoluzione industriale che è la nascita
del plc quindi di un sistema
programmabile cosa ci aspetta in un
futuro prossimo o abbastanza attuale la
terza rivoluzione robotica quella della
robotica mobile in cui robot come questo
stanno lavorando potranno lavorare su
dei sistemi mobili agv che si muovono
nelle aziende o anche nelle case perché
no e la quarta quella dell'intelligenza
artificiale che per i robot significa
non ci sarà più bisogno dell'uomo per
programmarli perché loro grazie alle
loro esperienze e alle condizioni in
contorno si programmeranno da soli
grazie
[Applauso]